hi there steve kaufman here you know
originally today i was going to talk
about the importance of uncertainty the
willingness to accept uncertainty and
language learning because someone had
commented on that here at my channel and
of course it is so important in language
learning to accept that things remain
vague the only thing that's certain
is what you yourself commit to do so i
was going to talk about that in greater
detail but i'll save that for another
occasion because i'm going to talk today
about living language why because i
decided
that i would buy
living language greek
and
living language hebrew all right so i
just got them today so i'm quite excited
so i want to talk about that
so i uh and and so here's the point you
know i want to learn greek hebrew arabic
and turkish at home i have
uh i i don't know if it's
colloquial or teach yourself or living
language i have a starter set for arabic
and for turkish i haven't really done
much more than leaf through it
i'm here in palm springs
suddenly had the urge i went to amazon i
bought the greek
and the hebrew because those four call
them the the middle east central asia
the ancient world that's going to be the
next thing that i
go after
so
you know and i started looking at greek
at link
and of course the the sound quality of
of
some of the beginning beginner material
i think is very very good who is she in
greek it's excellent and of course with
the text to speech i can highlight a
word i can highlight a phrase i can hear
it pronounced all of this is very
important as as i'm trying to
familiarize myself with the greek
alphabet because that's the first step
until i can read
it's hard to really remember the sounds
for me at least unless i can visualize
that connection between the sound and
and what i'm reading so as i'm listening
through the first five lessons of who is
she and really not much is sticking
so
not only is the content fuzzy and
uncertain it's essentially
unintelligible i'm starting to notice
certain uh letters of the greek alphabet
and associate them with certain sounds i
got a long way to go and for a long long
time it's going to remain
uncertain but i have the certainty that
i will eventually
succeed i will eventually be under be
able to understand greek and then when i
get into arabic turkish and hebrew i'll
eventually be able to understand those
languages i won't be perfect there will
be gaps
i won't be able to say exactly what i
want
uh
partly because i'm not devoting myself
full time to it i'm still listening to
my polish and czech and ukrainian
podcasts and reading
newspaper articles that i import into
link from various online newspapers in
those languages
however the certainty is that i will
eventually get there so at any rate just
to comment a bit on on living language
they have the living language they first
of all they get four little books in
each set
in the case of greek one of the books is
just an exercise book with with empty
pages i'm not sure what that is all
about except maybe to fill in the box
because maybe the box
because hebrew doesn't have that so
maybe they have one standard size box
and so you end up in the case of
languages where the books themselves are
not thick enough you get a little
exercise book i'll show you what i mean
it's just empty pages anyway that's
always useful
um so and then they divided all of them
into they have the audio which i haven't
yet listened to
and then they have what they call
essential
intermediate and advanced
and i've really only looked at the greek
here
and their essential seems to consist
mostly of grammar notes
and vocabulary and lots of exercises now
from my experience i won't do the
exercises
but the grammar notes in a book
is actually quite nice to have because i
like books
and with books you can flip back and
forth very easily now i have googled
four
explanations of greek grammar but it's
nicer to have a little book so i do like
that and since and there's no real
content in this beginner book it's just
seems to be vocabulary and grammar
explanations
which in my case because i have linked
that's okay i have all the lessons that
i need and as i listen to the audio and
i read through and of course i can see
the meaning and in the case of who is
she there's 26 lessons there where i
know it because i've used that same
story in
russian i know it in english because i
wrote it
uh
what else did i use it i think i used it
in czech
so um you know i know what the story is
uh so but i start getting these
questions about the grammar so once you
become inquisitive about the grammar
that's a good time to read up on the
grammar so the more exposure i have
through this fuzzy uncertain can't quite
make it out text
the more exposure i have the more
interest that i am in am and the grammar
and the more i'm going to remember of
the grammar
one thing i found interesting is that um
you know for each lesson they say in
this lesson you will learn how to
describe something or someone use colors
and other common adjectives in greek
describe more than one person and thing
use what you've learned to describe your
house and family i very much doubt it
very much doubt it my experience is that
whether it be the colors or the names of
people in my family i learn it i forget
it i learned it i forget it it's not
because i've gone through this book that
i will learn it
what they then do so that the the
essential book seems to be grammar some
basic grammar basic phrases to get you
started
but no real
interesting content
then in the intermediate and advanced
books
they provide you with different units
where you do have sort of conversations
for example here in the
intermediate greek for example unit 4
using the telephone
and it promises that
by the end of this lesson you should be
able to talk about phone calls and
phones use the nominative and accusative
of definite and indefinite articles not
sure what that means use the nominated
and accusative of greek nouns
again my experience is remember
uncertainty i probably will not be able
to do that at the end of this lesson but
it will introduce these concepts and in
particular
if i'm doing this in conjunction with a
lot of listening and reading
it should be useful
for me
so i'm looking forward to doing that and
again i see lots of exercises which i
won't do
and then by the time you get to advanced
then again i'll just open these at
random pages
so in advance you have presumably more
advanced
conversations
and obviously there's audio for these
conversations
and again they probably promise that by
the end of this chapter you'll be able
to do this and that yeah at the end of
this lesson you'll be able to conjugate
passive voice verbs in the past tense
form the passive voice in the past tense
maybe but i doubt it
but then they have lots of grammar
explanations if the present stem ends in
whatever greek letters with instead of
uh in the active single past the stem
changes to
before
examples are so a lot of these kinds of
explanations and there's lots of them
will be useful to me only from my
experience after i've had a lot of
experience with the language so i'm
going to combine these books with my um
link where i get exposed to content and
learn words and phrases have
uncertainty about the grammar questions
about the grammar then i'll go after
these books see some grammar
explanations go back to listening to
this interesting content and if i were
to vote to devote myself to this
i would think that within
i don't know within a few weeks to a
month the greek alphabet would no longer
be a complete mystery although it would
be a little difficult more difficult to
read than the latin alphabet and in time
i would understand what i'm listening to
and in time i would begin to get a sense
of the grammar
but if i go to use the language probably
still make mistakes in terms of endings
in terms of whatever they had their past
passive particle and stuff like that it
doesn't matter i know in this whole
world of uncertainty that as long as i
continue
on the task i will eventually get there
and there's another element of
uncertainty i don't know how much i will
achieve in how short a period of time
and it really doesn't matter the thought
that i will be able to read greek that
if i should go to greece and i see signs
i'd be able to read them and understand
some of it
gives me a great sense of anticipated
satisfaction and i know that i'll
eventually get there so there you have
it uncertainty and the living language
system and i will talk further as i get
into this and provide some more feedback
bye for now
[Music]
you